chris harrison is having a difficult
time after being replaced in bachelor
nation
i don't know if i should tell you this
it has learned the 49 year old reality
host is quote
concerned about the backlash following
his controversial remarks
which resulted in him temporarily
stepping away from the bachelor
franchise
it's the final rose tonight on monday a
guest host was announced for the
bachelors after the final rose special
with former nfl star emanuel acho
stepping in for harrison
now a source tells us quote chris and
his team are concerned about this ordeal
and the changes occurring they're trying
to figure out his next move
chris is a hard-working guy who loves
his job
meanwhile acho is thrilled about his new
gig
as long as there's good things being
discussed e.t source added quote
emmanuel acho is very excited to host
the after the final rose episode
he feels confident about replacing chris
harrison for the episode
and believes he can lead important
conversations that viewers should learn
about
and be part of this one hour special
will have acho sitting down with matt
james to discuss his season
we'll see conversations with the final
three women bree michelle
and rachel not a good look not a great
move
harrison first revealed he was taking
time off from the franchise in february
in his second apology for defending
contestant rachel kirkconnell's racist
actions
harrison said quote i was so wrong and
he felt quote ashamed
as a result the longtime host added he
would be stepping away from bachelor
nation for quote
a period of time i think the bachelor of
bachelorette
is always a sign of the times not vice
versa et spoke with harrison in december
about how the bachelor franchise has
been impacted by social issues
i don't think we you know wag the dog
the dog wags the tail and so
you know i think we're a microcosm of
what's going on out there and obviously
black lives matter and and racial
injustices and where that stands as a
he's a huge
topic and so these are topics that are
affecting everybody in the world right
now so yeah it
should bleed into the pages of the
bachelor and bachelorette and and so we
encourage that